MIGUEL HERNAN: Many interesting
things happened during the 1980s.
One of those things was
the launching in 1983
of a large randomized trial on
folic acid and birth defects.
This was the MRC vitamin
study, which included women
from 33 countries who were
planning to get pregnant.
Amazingly, the risk of neural tube
birth defects, a type of birth defect
was reduced by 70% in the
group assigned to folic acid.
And this was a big deal, because
neural tube birth defects
are serious birth defects that happen
when the central nervous system does
not close in the first
28 days of pregnancy.
And this lack of closure can lead to
very serious disabilities or death.
So the findings from the trial
were used to support major changes
in public health policy.
In the United States, the
Centers for Disease Control
advises all women to take than 0.4
milligrams of folic acid every day
before getting pregnant.
And many countries have implemented
mandatory fortification of wheat flour
with folic acid.
So women can get their daily dose
of folic acid from their food.
However, the MRC vitamin trial
left some questions unanswered.
First, this study only included
women with history of pregnancies
affected by neural tube defects.
So would folic acid to work
for the rest of the women?
And second, the study gave
women high doses of folic acid.
Would the same effect be seen
with the lower and possibly safer
doses that were usually included
in multi-vitamin supplements?
Since no randomized trials were
available to answer these questions,
investigators did what they always do.
They analyzed data from
observational studies.
And one of those studies was the
Sloan Epidemiology Unit Birth Defects
Study at Boston University.
This observational study included
pregnancies from several North American
cities in the 1990s.
And this study estimated that
the risk of birth defects
was 35% lower among pregnancies
exposed to folic acid.
35% lower, that's a strong association.
Can we then conclude that
folic acid at the usual doses
lowers the risk of neural tube
defects by 35% in normal women?
Well, maybe more educated
women take more vitamins
and also, do other things that
reduce risk of birth defects.
If that is the case,
then we would expect
to find a lower risk of birth
defects in folic acid users,
even if folic acid had no effect
on the risk of birth defects,
or it might be the other way around.
Maybe women with a history of
birth defects take more vitamins,
and these women are at the higher risk
of having a baby with birth defects.
If that were the case,
then our analysis would
underestimate the beneficial effects
of folic acid on birth defects.
Folic acid might reduce
the risk by, say, 50%,
but because the high risk women
are more likely to take folic acid,
we only see a 35% lower risk.
Like any observational
study, this one may
be affected by confounding,
which means that in our analysis,
we will need to adjust for
variables, like education
and prior history of birth defects.
And in particular, it turns out that
there is a variable L in our dataset.
And if we adjust for L, the
estimate moves from a 35% reduction
to only a 20% reduction in risk.
That's a big change.
So do we need to adjust for L then?
What is the closest to the
true effect of folic acid?
The unadjusted estimate of 35% lower
risk or the L adjusted estimate
of 20% lower risk?
Questions like this arise
constantly in research studies.
And by the end of this lesson, you will
know how to handle these questions.
You will be able to explain
under which circumstances
you would want to adjust
for the variable L
to quantify the effect of folic acid
on the risk of neural tube defects.